what'd you have for dinner are they good
huh
yeah where are you going
all right so you were coming this way
towards the highway
okay
so how did we end upside down
yes so basically the girl they called in
1907. she said right after she heard the
boom she called me okay she didn't sleep
the actual accident but she said I'll
grab all of her information yep so she
said her boyfriend actually did uh
but the boyfriend is not seeing I've
been talking to him so I tried calling
him he's not picking him
that was
sort of came from the restaurant but she
didn't happen
I want to say where she was coming from
okay I'm gonna probably that's the
camera dealership
all right I'm gonna bring her
absolutely
I'm going to take care of the police in
here for the first test can we have
whoever's car that is either face East
and just whatever lights are facing East
to have those on and have the back on
grooves okay there's no flashing the
same if we can do the same with this one
too okay so shut off those lights yeah
if you have a vehicle facing outwards
and just the lights that are facing
hours have those on flashlight
right down the center
and you're right here
so you have some privacy
so you have some privacy yeah okay so
you could stand right here for me what I
want to do is I want to do some tests to
make sure you get the drive okay
what's that I said I would like to do
some tests to make sure you're good to
drive okay I'm not driving you're not
driving anymore okay yeah I said I want
to make sure you are good to drive
because the whole reason we're here is
because your car is currently upside
down on the road yeah so I want to make
sure you're good to drive yeah I'm not
driving I understand you're not
currently okay yeah all right so can you
stand right here for me yeah throw it on
my flashlight being right there
what I would like you to do is put your
feet together like that and Hands by
your side outside of your pockets okay
[Laughter]
I gave
it
so were you wearing your seatbelt during
the accident yes
smack your head no
let me see if you get her together
touching okay just like mine
yeah
there you go
all right so you're not diabetic you
wear contacts or glasses yeah
but I'd like to do is like the tip of my
pen with your eyes and your eyes only
keep your head still okay do you
understand yes
keep your head still
uh you want me to yeah I was trying to
follow the tip of my plan with your eyes
and your eyes only okay
skip hands on the side of your pants
please
thank you
foreign
keep your head straight please
next one I want you to imagine there's a
straight line right here okay
you understand
go ahead and put your left foot on that
straight line and if you would like to
do this without your I see you got like
little wedges if you'd like to do them
Barefoot you're more than welcome to
it's up to you okay go ahead and put
your left foot on that line
put your right foot in front of your
left with your heel touching your toe
nope don't start yet
just like I am
okay go back right there
put your left foot on the line
put your right foot in front of your
left with your heel touching your toe
and put your hands behind your side stay
in that position until I tell you to
begin do you understand yeah okay just
like I am
when I tell you the beginning you're
gonna take nine heal the toe steps on
that straight line you're gonna I'm
sorry
when I tell you to begin you're going to
take nine Heel To Toe steps on that
straight line you're going to look at
your feet count your steps out loud Keep
Your Hands by your side and make sure
your steps are feel the toe it's going
to look like this
one two three I did three you're gonna
do nine okay okay on your ninth step
keep your front foot on the line and
take a series of small steps and return
with nine heel of toe steps on the line
one two three again I did three you're
gonna do nine once you start don't stop
make sure you look at your feet while
you're walking count your steps out loud
Keep Your Hands by your side and make
sure your steps reveal the code you
understand I think so if you have any
questions
you can begin
three four five
continue the test
yep
do you remember the instructions I gave
you yeah
yeah
and then you were supposed to keep your
front foot on the line and take a series
of small steps for the other foot and
return with nine helicops on the line
do you want to try it again I want me to
give you the instructions again yeah
yeah okay let's come back over here
right there
all right so again stand right here a
little silhouette
so we're gonna imagine a straight line
okay okay put your left foot on the line
put your right foot in front of your
left with your heel touching your toe
and Put Your Hands by your side
just like I am
do you want to get dry
just like I am and stay in this position
until I tell you to begin do you
understand
just how I am right foot in front of
your left with your heel touching your
top
all right nope
right foot in front of your left
nope ma'am I haven't told you to start
yet
just let's see how I'm standing
just like that left foot on the line
right foot in front of your left with
your heel touching your toe Hands by
your side and stay in that position
until I tell you to begin and
when I tell you the beginning you're
gonna take nine feel the toe steps on
that straight line
you're gonna count your steps out loud
look at your feet and keep your hands by
your side hold on let me finish
constructing it's going to look like
this okay yeah
one two three I did three you're gonna
do nine on your ninth step keep your
front foot on the line and take a series
of small steps and return with nine
pillow toe steps on the line
one two three again I did three you're
gonna do nine okay
make sure you look at your feet while
you're walking count your steps out loud
Keep Your Hands by your side make sure
your steps are kill the toe and once you
start don't stop do you understand
okay
you can begin
three four five
remember the turn I instructed you to do
no
are you done
all right
well when you guys have your department
phones
no longer there
um
heels and Toes touch them
okay
when I tell you to begin I want to take
a foot of your choice doesn't matter
which one
Sarge
behind you
hold on
I want you to pick a foot of your choice
doesn't matter which one I want you to
look for approximately six inches off
the ground you're going to point your
toe on people with your legs straight
and you're going to look at that foot
that you have raised and count out loud
it's gonna look like this one thousand
one one thousand two one thousand three
until I tell you to stop okay do you
understand
if you have any questions
okay
you can begin
one two
one one
two three four five six
what's up
you don't want to continue I don't
know one two three
three okay
corner
I'm gonna explain it to you I'm gonna
bring listen I'm gonna bring you over to
my car so you have a little more privacy
okay when you guys gonna be able to
bother it
thank you
and we're going to